While many fans couldn't really make sense
of Jared Leto's Joker in Suicide Squad, there's
no arguing against the fact that the movie's
Clown Prince of Crime had a really unique
look.
But now, writer-director David Ayer has confessed
that he made a mistake with the character's
design.
Whether you love it or you hate it, Jared
Leto's Joker design makes an impression.
From his pale white skin and bright green
hair to his eye-catching tattoos and silver
teeth, he has a look that screams "gangster
meets prankster".
But was this stylized design really the right
approach?
Over two years after Suicide Squad's theatrical
run, Ayer has confessed that he now considers
one particular piece of Leto's Joker design
to be a total mistake.
The admission came about thanks to a fan on
Twitter, who asked Ayer about the Joker's
eye-catching forehead tattoo the one that
simply reads: "Damaged".
When asked what inspired that particular bit
of ink, Ayer admitted that it was his idea
and he regrets it.
The director responded to the query with a
mea culpa, writing,
"Yes I have to fall on that sword.
It was one step too far."
Even after owning up to what he now feels
was a bad move, Ayer affirmed that he still
generally likes the tattoo, at least in concept.
He also gave some insight into his thought
process as to why the Joker would have such
a statement scribbled across his cranium.
In a follow-up post, Ayer wrote,
"In my mind it was meant for Batman after
he smashed Joker['s] teeth for killing Jason
Todd.
Some people found it alienating.
Originality and faithfulness to the canon
are often at odds.
Batman and Joker are my two favorite characters
ever."
Ayer offered a similar explanation for the
Joker's "damaged" tattoo around the time Suicide
Squad launched in theaters, saying that Joker
would have gotten the tattoo while locked
up in Arkham Asylum after being scooped up
by the Dark Knight.
As he told Empire in August 2016,
"It's in the asylum where Joker would have
done the 'damaged' tattoo as a message to
Batman saying, 'You've damaged me.
I was so beautiful before and now you've destroyed
my face.'
That's where the grill comes from."
As it happens, Ayer has quite a few regrets
about the decisions he made with Suicide Squad,
many of which come down to choices made about
the Joker.
Not only does Ayer now wish he didn't ink
up the Joker's forehead, he also regrets not
making the character the main bad guy of the
movie's story.
Despite being heavily featured in the movie's
promotional materials, Jared Leto's Joker
only has about ten total minutes of screen
time in the theatrical cut of Suicide Squad
far less than what was originally shot for
the supervillain picture.
Even people who enjoyed the movie have said
that it could have been improved by an increased
focus on the evil jester, and some have approached
Ayer on Twitter with their thoughts.
In response to one fan who wrote him a year
after the movie's release, Ayer said,
"Believe me.
I agonize over this.
Yes.
Joker should have been [the] main bad guy."
"Yeah."
Ayer has been expressing some disappointment
in the final cut of Suicide Squad since shortly
after the film opened in theaters.
In January 2017, the director penned a lengthy
post detailing what he wished he'd done differently,
then shared a screenshot of the note on his
Twitter page.
In the post, he wished for a time machine
to undo the errors that he feels he made,
along with a determination to do better next
time.
As for what he'd do differently, he said,
"I'd make Joker the main villain and engineer
a more grounded story.
I have to take the good and bad and learn
from it […] I have to give the characters
the stories and plots they deserve next time.
Real talk."
As we know now, he'd also do away with that
distracting tattoo.
Ayer's self-criticism is refreshing, but he
doesn't have to be so tormented.
As divisive as Suicide Squad turned out to
be upon release, the movie still performed
well enough for Warner Bros. and DC to turn
a massive profit off of it.
And despite the critical drubbing, plenty
of fans still truly enjoyed the film, Joker
and all.
It can even be argued that Ayer crafted the
most unforgettable version of the Joker that
has yet to grace the screen, making a major
impact on pop culture despite the character's
slight screen time.
Like the rest of Suicide Squad, Ayer's Joker
isn't necessarily a disaster.
It's just a little damaged.